oh he is freaking again
he is freaking we gotta agree with
frozone here
watching the animators and voice actors
put the incredibles two together
is pretty freaky just like the parr
family the incredibles crew rolled with
the punches to create a knockout movie
from enthusiastic line reading to
state-of-the-art animation techniques
the incredibles 2 used years of
preparation to create a spectacular film
but that doesn't mean there weren't a
few blunders along the way
wait a minute you're saying what
believe it or not the incredibles don't
do everything together as a family
in fact when they were recording their
lines for the incredibles 2
they were alone with their most
formidable foe yet the director
right right right yeah good okay so
director brad bird
isn't that scary he's actually like a
big teddy bear but the actors definitely
had their work cut out for them trying
to get their lines just right
for one they aren't even given full
scripts when they come in to record
they're only given their lines and some
direction about how each character was
supposed to feel
uh make it like a private whisper to
yourself like
the rest is up to the superhero voice
actors who made solo studio time sound
pretty incredible
there is one perk to being the only
actor in the sound booth the amazing
solo freakouts that are just as
hilarious to us
as they are to the voice actors just
look at sophia bush who brought
enthusiastic superhero void to life
wow wow it must be hard to fangirl over
superheroes when they're the only one in
the recording studio
but sophia makes void sound like she's
surrounded by every one of her super
powered icons
even after doing the lines over and over
and over again
oh yeah okay joining sophia with another
epic freak out is craig t
nelson who voices the one and only mr
incredible remember that scene when bob
was trying to help dash with his dreaded
math homework
well craig looked just as upset about
math when he was in the recording studio
and let's be honest if you decided to
become a superhero
math probably wasn't one of your
strengths anyway math is
math math is math
helen parr is the feminist icon we all
need she saves the world and her family
and still makes it home in time for
dinner
she does this all with so much
flexibility
i'm not all dark and angsty i'm
elastigirl i'm you know
flexible no one can tell elastigirl what
to do well
except for rad bird who was telling
everyone what to do he made sure holly
hunter the incredible voice behind our
fave female superhero
always set her lines with just the right
amount of attitude holly just had to
make sure to pepper a lot of fake
laughter in there to perfectly capture
lastico's level of annoyance
[Music]
but then there are some voice actors
like catherine keener as evelyn dever
who just couldn't seem to make a mistake
look at her crush this line in just one
take
things would have been different that's
it really we could
almost forgive her for also trying to
crush superheroes everywhere
almost actually we almost got to see
evelyn as a superhero instead of a
villain
can you imagine how different the movie
would have been apparently the villain
kept changing throughout development
catherine herself didn't even know about
evelyn's sudden shift to evil
until she was given her lines for the
scene where she forces the mind control
goggles
onto elastigirl that's a pretty rude
awakening to your suddenly evil nature
but catherine rolled with it like
planning to mind control all superheroes
is just part of her day job
while catherine had to experience
evelyn's descent into evil
bob odenkirk had an entirely different
experience as her brother winston
endeavour brad bird said winston was
supposed to be a huge jerk who was
obsessed with his own ego
you know one of those types spectacular
but bob just radiated such genuinely
energy
that he completely transformed the
character into a genuinely nice person
who really loves superheroes i love
superheroes
the powers the costumes the mythic
struggles
we're happy at least one of the
different siblings wasn't a total fake
the incredibles 2 is packed with action
and super speedy superheroes
but how do they get that superhero
movement just right well
let's just say dash moves a lot more
slowly in the animation process
than he does once he makes it to the big
screen this behind the scene footage
gave us a quick look at how animators
make dash move so quickly
and it involves hours and hours of
sketching think you'd have the patience
to help animate the next incredibles
movie
speaking of animation the incredibles
crew worked hard to bring fan favorite
character to life for the sequel
but she never actually made it in the
final cut brad bird originally wanted
frozone's wife honey to be animated this
time around
and they went so far as to come up with
a character design and draw a whole
scene of her entrance
ultimately they decided she's funnier as
just a voice
leading us to wonder if she'll ever show
up in an incredibles movie
let us know in the comments if you're
ready for honey to finally have our big
break
here's an insane fact for you the
incredibles 2 had a whole team of people
whose job it is to go into every single
shot of the movie
and make sure that the hair is reacting
and moving correctly yep
the hair the pixar hair program was
entirely changed for this movie
the last time they worked on it it was
for monsters inc with their new program
they were able to create longer more
versatile hair that's pretty realistic
they used this technology to make
violet's hair longer this time around
so she could hide behind it more
effectively when she was feeling shy
you had to have wondered why boyd's
character is super extreme
all the time maybe she reminds you of
something like
an excited puppy if you thought that
then you're right on the money because
brad bird
actually based her off of his dog who
has two moods
i love you and i'm sorry but void's
enthusiastic nervous hand movements are
all sophia bush
if you look at her reading her lines
alongside the animation it looks like
sophia is acting just as much as voicing
the excited superhero
i feel like
brad's dog isn't the only part he put in
the film he actually both created and
voiced his fan favorite character edna
mode
this probably isn't the face you
imagined behind edna but brad does an
incredible job of bringing edna's
attitude to the big screen darling
she's his pride and joy character after
all
the voice acting process may have been
lonely but the collaboration
really shown in the art and animation
department with all the pieces involved
it's no wonder the sequel took 14 years
to make behind the scene footage gave us
an inside look at how all
different departments get together and
discuss things they love and hate about
the film
so that it can be edited down to
perfection before it hits the big screen
brad's there of course since it's his
movie but he also sits back and lets his
team give their honest opinions
so are these the real superheroes behind
the incredibles it definitely seems like
it
did you know the incredibles actually
takes place in the 60s
the movie seems high-tech and modern but
its 60s retro mixed with advanced
technology
to match the 60s vibes all characters
had retro style icons on which their
fashion and hairstyles were based
helen's style is based on marilyn tyler
moore marilyn monroe
and audrey hepburn while bob's style is
based on paul newman
did you spot any fashion moments in the
incredibles 2 that were definitely based
on the 60s
feel free to share them with us in the
comments for the incredibles 2
they didn't skimp on an epic orchestra
they played live and together to record
all the music
and it's incredible to see them in
action just look at how many people it
takes to make the magic and drama of a
superhero movie come to life
these soundtrack heroes deserve a round
of applause for keeping us on the edge
of our seats
that's really cool yeah
finally let's talk about how voice
actors and animators work together the
line reading comes first
and then as brad explains the animators
listen to the recordings over and over
again until they make the personality of
the voices shine
through the animated characters they
animate and reanimate until it's a
perfect
fit and sometimes they have to even
change things last minute and record new
lines
but they figured out seamless ways of
making these changes happen as quickly
as possible
dash might be the one with super speed
but these animators race to the clock
every day to bring our favorite
superhero family to life
so do you have a favorite incredibles
voice actor which parts of the animation
process impressed you the most
drop all your thoughts in the comments
and don't forget to hit that like button
and subscribe to the things for more
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time